wow there was supposed to be a ceasefire
but these latest videos show no pause in
the violence a week after the first
shots were fired on Saturday the 15th of
April there's fighting still across
cartoon the capital of Sudan the rapid
support forces or rsf claim they're
advancing through the city posting
videos like this one but the official
Army the Sudanese armed forces have also
struck back this shows their aircraft
flying over the city it is a complicated
picture we can show you where those
incidents took place across the capital
here they are now hundreds of people are
confirmed to have died although the
number is likely to be higher Sky News
has verified the status of all these
hospitals in the city Orange shows the
ones that have been attacked and
evacuated White shows the places they've
been evacuated the blue pins show
hospitals that have suspended their
services and those in yellow are open
but they are classed as under threat now
this is one of the hospitals that has
been damaged we don't know whether it
was specifically targeted or who it and
there's another danger to civilians the
Sudan doctors Union posted these
pictures of unexploded Munitions in the
city warning people not to approach them
as they could explode at any moment the
country's de facto president General
Abdel fatal burhan has addressed the
nation
we're confident that we will overcome
this ordeal with our training wisdom and
strength preserving the security and
unity of the state allowing us to be
entrusted with the safe transition to
civilian rule
foreign
there's some skepticism to put it mildly
of that commitment to civilian rule in
2019 people took to the streets
demanding that the then president who'd
ruled the country for decades resign he
was deposed in the military coup with a
promise that Sudan would transition to
civilian leadership but another coup put
the military back in charge and locked
two generals in a power struggle General
Abdel fatah al-bohan is the head of the
Sudanese armed forces and the country's
de facto president and his Deputy was
General Mohammed Hamden daglow better
known as hamiti the commander of the
rapid support forces a militia accused
of Human Rights abuses thought to be
about a hundred thousand strong now one
of the points of the power struggle is a
plan to incorporate the rsf into the
country's official Army and who would be
in charge of that for now though both
sides are trying to seize key
infrastructure especially khartoum's
airport this is what it looked like on
the satellite view before the fighting
started and this is what happened after
you can see a large plume of smoke on
that Airfield and the latest satellite
imagery we have you see the smoke has
cleared away you can see the damage has
been done with lots of wreck planes
planes that haven't been able to move
because this airport is out of action
and that is complicating other aspects
of this both the evacuation of foreign
Nationals and a plan to send the
presence of neighboring countries
intermediate in Sudan now the U.S has a
military base in nearby Djibouti that
could be used for evacuation and it is
planning on sending a large number of
extra troops there if the violence
continues British military aircraft are
being prepared too there are fears the
violence could draw in neighboring
states Ethiopia Chad and South Sudan
have all been afflicted by conflict and
upheaval and Ethiopia has clashed with
Sudan over disputed borders beyond that
the Egyptian Military and a powerful
Libyan militia are reportedly backing
different sides with military supplies
leading to fears of an entrenched
conflict and fully fledged Civil War